- Please welcome someone
I just love so much
and think so highly of,
Topher Grace.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
- Hi guys, yeah.
I can't believe it.
- [Drew] I've Scarlett
coming along tomorrow.
- No way?
- Yes.
Yes. I love that movie.
- It's so good to see you.
- [Drew] Oh Topher, I'm
so happy to see you.
- I am the eight millionth person
to come on this show and say,
this is the truth,
that you are the nicest human in,
definitely Hollywood,
(audience applauds)
in the world, yeah.
I see you say thank you
so much, on this show,
to people all the time,
but I don't know if you remember this.
You shouldn't remember
this, but I remember this,
'cause I was pulled out
of a high school play
to be on 70's Show.
I'd never acted before "That 70's Show",
and I saw you at the
Nickelodeon's Kids Choice Award.
It was the first time I
ever presented an award
at an awards ceremony.
And someone came up to me and said,
"Hey, someone wants to say hi to you."
I said, "Oh okay."
He said, "It's Drew Barrymore"
- Oh, now I know what-
- I said, "Oh my God."
- you're talking about.
- No, of course no. Now I know
what you're talking about.
- You went on and on about
how much you liked the show.
- Yeah, I was a huge fan!
- And it was genuine.
At first, I thought it was
maybe like a Hollywood thing
and then you were citing different things
I'd done on the show.
And I drove home whistling.
I was so...
I thought, oh my God, someone believes it.
And the fact that I...
I mean, you're such an icon,
I couldn't believe you
were saying that to me.
And then...
and then the show did hit,
you're such a wonderful
person, I'm so grateful.
- Oh my God, thank you
so much for saying that.
(audience applauds)
Okay. So you did something
that just has had me
all in a lather about,
did you crash the Academy Awards?
- Yeah. Right, so...
- How did you do that?
- I've been when I was invited,
but before I went, I was still at USC
and USC used to be
right across the street.
- Shrine.
- Yeah.
- Right across from the Shrine Auditorium,
which the Academy was at for decades.
- And we were up drinking
on a parking garage-
- Yes!
I already love this story.
- And my buddy goes,
"I bet if we just drove
a limo in tomorrow,
just got in that limo line,
we could just hop out
of the car and walk in."
And I was like...
(audience reacts)
Yeah, there, that's me!
- Oh my God, you are a baby!
(audience applauds)
Oh my God.
You are a true little tiny
baby, look at that baby face.
- That's two months before
I started "That 70's Show".
We couldn't even afford...
- That's like two months
before you hit puberty!
(audience laughs)
- It's one and the same, one and the same.
We got in the limo, we pulled up,
we got out of the car, waved,
everyone in the audience
goes like, "Whoa, like, who?"
And by the time they knew that
they didn't know who we were,
we got in there and we
were on the red carpet.
We saw Tyra Banks, which
is a big deal for us.
And then we saw you!
(Drew squeals)
(audience applauds)
- Was it the year I had
the daisies in my hair?
- Yeah, you had, I know you
got a big thing for, yep.
(audience applaud and whoop)
- I love it so much, buddy, good for you.
That is...
That's the kinda spirit
that speaks to me.
I love that moxie.
That actually dovetails perfectly
into something I also
have to ask you about,
which is this text chain with
Tom Cruise and Meryl Streep.
Topher, spill it all.
Tell me everything.
- Well, look, we've been
looking for a project.
The three of us.
No, we, um, (laughs)
(audience laughs)
I was bored, it was a pandemic.
I stole my wife's phone
and I made fake texts
where I'm like- (laughs)
this isn't actually from
Meryl Streep, I should say,
where she's just talking about
how much she loves my acting.
And Tom Cruise is...
and I did one from Daniel Day Lewis,
where he's like "Teach
me, teach me your ways.
I wanna learn how to be a good actor."
- [Drew] So wait, do you
go in your wife's phone
and create a contact?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- 'Cause it looks legit.
I love this.
- Yeah.
- Okay, so if you were to text
Meryl Streep in real life,
what would you say to Meryl?
- "Oh my God, you're the
greatest of all time.
Sorry for texting you."
(audience laughs)
- And Tom Cruise?
- I'd say, "Take it down a notch, dude.
You're gonna die."
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
"We don't need all these stunts,
you can use your stunt double."
(bright music)